In this video, we'll look at making a complex material
based on our Unity shader graph.
Here we see the Unity shader graph
for the scrolling texture on our pillars
around our dancer, as well as the logic
that allows us to switch the color
between the two of them.
In Unreal, this looks like this.
We're gonna be rebuilding a lot of similar logic
and a lot of functions will have very similar names.
So you should be able to follow this one
a little bit more closely.
So let's go ahead and jump in.
We'll create ourselves.
We already have a stage pillar matte right here,
which we can open up.
Perfect.
And now what we're gonna do first
is create our scrolling texture
and then we'll add in the color.
So we can do that first by getting a time node.
This will give us just a counting up of game time.
So I'll work inside of shader graph.
We'll use a panner node and our coordinates,
but we will use, plug that into time.
And I want this to have the speed be set to one.
So we'll be panning our Y coordinate.
And don't worry if shader math is not your thing.
This isn't as important and you can kind of follow along
and make some fun math tricks along the way.
We'll be using a multiply node
that we can kind of tweak and slow down
the panner speed if we want.
And we'll be piping that into a texture sample.
So this is where this node can be used
to grab any texture from your project
and apply it to a material.
And we are going to use,
we can see down here the texture we want to set.
We're gonna search for noise.
And we are gonna get our, let's pick a fun one.
And then we leave that over here for now.
We have this white if we want to
apply this texture sample.
We can plug this in here
and we should see it scrolling along
back to, oh, we're in the wrong map again.
Let's go back to our, we'll save that.
That's okay.
Come back over here.
And if we want to see our material on our cube.
So I guess the splitting it up,
I'm gonna need to split it now and get on there.
So we can see a preview of our material now
on this sphere to the side.
If we want to see what it will look like on a cube,
like the pillars we have in our scene,
we can just hit the cube over here
and now we get a better idea of what we're looking at.
So that looks pretty good so far.
I think another thing we can do though
in order to control how contrasty this noise is,
is add in a step node and I'll set this to 0.5 as well.
This is gonna make it a little more of a hard transition
when we're going from black to white.
This looks good.
We can set this to the side a little bit more over here.
Now what I'd like to do is set this color.
We're gonna pick this to be, double click here,
say let's go, we used pink and green
or purple and green, let's go purple.
And then another color here,
we can just duplicate that with control D,
click and we can pick our color from four, awesome.
So in order to switch between these two colors,
we're gonna use what's called alert node
or linear interpolate.
And so this will allow us to switch between A and B
based off of this value of alpha.
And again, if you wanna see what this looks like,
you can also right click and do start preview.
And this will, instead of showing this output here
of the final material output,
it will show whatever this,
the output of just this specific node.
So this is like a blend now between our light purple
and our light green.
So if we wanna combine this with our texture down here,
we can use a multiply,
auto multiply, so make sure you just get
the basic one for this.
We'll plug this in, plug that into base color,
stop previewing, and now we've got our color
applied to our noise.
If we put this down to zero,
you can see we're all the way at purple
and if we put this to one,
we're all the way to green, awesome.
We can apply this, and then in order to be able
to change this color, what we need to do
is make this a constant.
So this will allow us to set,
if we, and then a parameter,
and we will call this color one, two, two.
So now, change the value of this parameter,
it will change the value of our material.
And then one last thing for now,
we are going to come down here to another multiply
and we will pipe in another parameter here,
constant, convert to parameter,
and we will call this glow intensity,
set this to something like five,
and then hook this up to our emissive color.
And so now this is going to allow our material
to have an effect on the Lumen global illumination system.
And from here, we'll get to see our cubes
and our stage pillars generating patterns
as our glowing cubes are able to go from zero to one.
So this is all well and good
and we can actually convert these to parameters
so that they can change in material instances.
And you do that just by right-clicking
and telling them to convert to parameters.
In order to make this interactive,
we're gonna need a way to change the color of our,
or change that number that controls
the color of our cubes dynamically.
There are a couple ways of changing the value
of a parameter on a material at runtime.
One of them is by using a dynamic instance of the material
or the other way is by using
a material parameter collection.
We're gonna look at this material parameter collection
cause it's one of the unique assets
and part of the Unreal Engine workflow
that can be really powerful.
It's designed for being able to update
large groups of materials simultaneously,
but we're just gonna see how it works with the one here
cause it gives us a little bit more flexibility
in our code.
So we're gonna be creating it in the content browser,
creating a new parameter,
and then we can add it to our material
that we were just working on.
Over here, I'll right-click,
I'll go to material and we see
in material parameter collection,
I'll call this MPC session blur change, fantastic.
We'll open this up and we can see all we're doing
is putting in a list of scalar parameters.
So just one float value or a vector parameter,
so an array of float values.
In this case, we create one
and I'll call this color change,
we can call this info
and this is the default value of zero, which is fine.
Now back over here in our color map
or in our material,
we can look for a parameter collection parameter.
It's already seen that we want
to get our session color change
and we will grab our value for A to B
and then instead of using the parameter in the material,
we will use this material parameter collection.
Perfect, so this is gonna allow us
to change the value, have our other blueprints
change the value here in this asset
and that will be propagated to any material
that incorporates that same parameter.
For this, we're gonna do it in the level blueprint
and then we're gonna migrate it
into a new third person character.
In the next video, we'll look at how the player
can use their input to drive the logic of our material
as well as the animation blueprint we created earlier.